This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个爱心播客。保证真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难之路》，我是你们最喜欢的心疗师兼主持人卡尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方其实并不安全，但你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副重铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。这并不意味着你需要这么做，收听《学习》。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难之路》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWA percent，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. There are some episodes that I do just for me. You know, no one is really asked for them. I'm just super fascinated by the topic or it's just really showing up in my own life. And I feel like I can't move past it unless I do an episode on it, like that sort of thing.
相信你的闺蜜。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析我们二十多岁的心理学。有些节目我纯粹是为自己做的。你知道，其实没有人要求做这些。我只是对这个话题超级着迷，或者它真实地呈现在我自己的生活中。我觉得如果不做一期关于它的节目，我就无法释怀，就是那种感觉。
So like the recent episodes that I've done on how to pursue your creative passion, that was one of those, as was the one on hobbies. and then there are the episodes that you all, the listeners, are almost begging me to do. And any time I ask for topic suggestions, anytime I ask people to guess what episode is coming next, overwhelmingly I get this response. Please talk about the psychology behind male, female friendships,
所以就像我最近做的关于如何追求你的创意激情的节目一样，那期就是其中之一，关于兴趣爱好的那期也是如此。然后还有一些节目，你们这些听众几乎是在求着我做。每当我征求话题建议时，每当我让大家猜接下来的节目是什么时，我都会压倒性地收到这样的回应。请聊聊男女友谊背后的心理学，
why they seem so rare, why they can be so hard, what makes them work, what makes them doesn't. And today, my friends, is the day that we talk about it because, you know, I have to give the people what they want. And I have to also give you all the psychological answers behind this big question. Can men and women be friends? I think the reason that it's taken me so long to do this episode is because I don't want
为什么它们看起来如此罕见，为什么它们会如此艰难，是什么让它们维系，又是什么让它们破裂。今天，我的朋友们，就是我们探讨这个话题的日子，因为，你知道的，我必须满足大众的需求。而且我还要为这个宏大的问题提供你们所有人都在寻找的心理学答案。男女之间能成为朋友吗？我想我之所以花了这么长时间才做这期节目，是因为我不想
it to be like surface level so as not to offend anyone. I don't want to make general claims and like gloss over the facts and the research. I wanted to really go deep into this question of whether men and women can be friends, the age old when Harry met Sally trope. And in doing that, we are going to explore so much. We're going to explore how societal expectations around gender and friendship have changed over the past 60 years, what the key difference is between male to male and female to female friendships, non-binary and queer friendships, before really jumping into what makes male-female friendships
为了不冒犯任何人而流于表面。我不想做出笼统的断言，然后对事实和研究敷衍了事。我想深入探讨男女能否成为朋友这个问题，也就是老生常谈的《当哈利遇到莎莉》的梗。在这样做的过程中，我们将进行广泛的探索。我们将探讨过去60年里围绕性别和友谊的社会期望发生了怎样的变化，男男友谊与女女朋友谊之间、非二元性别和酷儿友谊之间的关键区别是什么，然后再深入探讨是什么让男女友谊
in particular so tricky, whether it is just romantic attraction or something deeper, like communication or expectations, but why also these kinds of friendships when they work are really important and really fulfilling. We'll also touch on what happens when one person gets feelings, how to reassert boundaries, and some stories from the listeners. I asked you guys to submit your opinions and your stories on this, good, bad and ugly about your experience with male-female friendships. One thing that I got out of all of those DMs is that there is not a general consensus when it comes to this question.
特别是如此棘手，究竟是因为浪漫吸引力，还是更深层次的东西，比如沟通或期望，但也探讨为什么这类友谊一旦成功就非常重要且极具成就感。我们还将触及当一方产生好感时会发生什么、如何重新确立边界，以及听众的一些故事。我请大家就此提交你们的看法和故事，关于你们的男女友谊经历，无论是好是坏还是糟糕透顶。从所有这些私信中我得出的一点是，关于这个问题并没有普遍的共识。
I definitely have my own opinion because I do have quite a few really close male friends that will always be platonic, but you all, the last. listeners, you also had opinions and there was not a single, you know, overarching, overwhelming answer. So we're really going to dive into some of the fascinating studies done on this in social psychology, debunk some of the misconceptions, but also provide a bit of a checklist for what makes male female friendships work. If you can't already tell, you are in for a treat and a big discussion. So I hope you are strapped in. I hope you are excited to learn. or perhaps to maybe confirm something that you already did know.
我当然有我自己的看法，因为我确实有几个非常要好的男性朋友，我们的关系将永远是柏拉图式的，但你们所有人，也就是听众们，也有你们的看法，并没有一个单一的、统领全局的、压倒性的答案。因此，我们将深入探讨社会心理学中关于此课题的一些迷人研究，揭穿一些误区，并为如何让男女友谊维系下去提供一份简明的清单。如果你还没看出来的话，你今天将大饱眼福并听到一场深刻的讨论。所以我希望你们已经系好安全带。我希望你们兴奋地去学习，或者也许是为了证实你已经知道的某些事情。
But without further ado, let us talk about the psychology of male-female friendships. I want you to do a quick exercise for me right now. How many friends do you have that are the same gender as you? I want you to keep counting until you reach maybe maximum of 15. Now, how many friends do you have of the opposite gender? They can't be partners of friends. That's a big one. They can't be related to you.
但废话少说，让我们来谈谈男女友谊的心理学。我想现在让我做个小练习。你有多少个与你同性别的同性朋友？我希望你一直数，直到数到最多15个。那么，你有多少个异性朋友？他们不能是朋友的伴侣。这是一个关键点。他们不能与你有亲戚关系。
They can't be people that you have previously been romantically involved with. Chances are that the second number is much smaller than the first. For most of us, our friendship preferences do tend to be skewed towards people of the same gender because there is a lived experience there that we share, but also we've been socialized by society in the same way. So we are more likely to enjoy the same activities, like the same things, have similar language and a way of communicating. And research really does show that people often form friendships with those of a similar age, religion, education, occupation, and also gender. With some exceptions, of course, one study did find that younger gay and bisexual men are more likely to have cross-gender friendships while lesbian women are not. they're more likely to have more female friends.
他们不能是与你曾有过恋爱关系的人。第二个数字很有可能比第一个数字小得多。对我们大多数人来说，我们的友谊偏好往往倾向于同性别的人，因为我们在那里有着共同的生活经历，而且我们也受到了社会以相同方式的社会化塑造。因此，我们更有可能享受相同的活动，喜欢相同的事物，拥有相似的语言和沟通方式。研究确实表明，人们往往会与年龄、宗教、教育、职业以及性别相似的人建立友谊。当然也有一些例外，一项研究确实发现，较年轻的男同性恋和双性恋男性更有可能拥有跨性别友谊，而女同性恋女性则不然。她们更有可能拥有更多的女性朋友。
I think it's also worth noting that not a lot, actually very little of this research has been done on this population and very little has been done on non-binary people as well. So that is a big research gap. If anyone needs a PhD topic or a thesis idea, non-binary friendship preferences by gender or something like that, would be very interesting. But as a general rule, women tend to be friends with more women
我认为同样值得注意的是，针对这一群体的研究并不多，实际上非常少，针对非二元性别者的研究也非常少。所以这是一个巨大的研究空白。如果有人需要博士论文题目或毕业论文构想，比如“按性别划分的非二元性别友谊偏好”之类的主题，会非常有趣。但作为一般规律，女性往往倾向于与更多的女性交朋友，
and they express greater closeness to their female friends, and the same goes for men. There are a few reasons for this, some of which we've already mentioned, but I think a large part of this gender divide is actually quite historical, and it's remnant of a time where male-female relations could not be platonic. You were either courting, married, or family, and even then, there was still a great deal of separation. We had male quarters, female quarters as an example. A woman couldn't be alone with a man who was not family or her husband. That's still the case in some parts of the world.
并且她们对女性朋友表现出更高的亲密感，男性也是如此。造成这种情况的原因有几个，其中一些我们已经提到过，但我认为这种性别分工很大程度上实际上具有历史渊源，它是那个男女关系不可能纯粹是柏拉图式的时代的遗留物。你们当时要么是在谈恋爱、结婚，要么就是亲戚，即便如此，依然存在着巨大的隔阂。比如我们有男区、女区。一个女人不能和一个非亲非故、也不是她丈夫的男人独处。在世界某些地方，情况依然如此。
So that makes it kind of hard to be friends with someone of the opposite gender, doesn't it? It's not very likely. We can also trace this general pattern back to potentially things like the division of labour, so men historically went out hunting, women participated in. in child rearing and, you know, women only recently, and by recently, I mean in the last 100 years, entered the workplace where they actually had a chance to make friends with men and had a chance to exit the home. That's only like three to four generations of progress. So this long historical division has also, like I mentioned before, changed how men and women were socialized
这使得与异性做朋友变得有点困难，对吧？不太可能发生。我们还可以将这种普遍模式追溯到诸如劳动分工之类的事情上，比如历史上男性出去打猎，女性参与抚养孩子，而且，你知道的，女性只是在最近——这里的最近指的是过去100年里——才进入职场，她们才真正有机会与男性交朋友，有机会走出家门。这仅仅是三到四代人的进步。因此，这种漫长的历史分工也像我之前提到的一样，改变了男性和女性被社会化
or conditioned, basically just a fancy word for how we were raised and the values and personalities that were instilled in us. Women are typically seen as more vulnerable than more feeling, giving, nurturing, that is the traditional consensus, whereas men have been seen as more adventurous, tough, less emotional. So that has dictated how they relate and interact with those of their own gender. So let me explain this a little bit first. So there was this really cool research study done at Duke University in 2016, and it wanted to see the difference within female-female friendships and male-male friendships. It found that women, we tend to lean into self-disclosure when hanging out.
或塑造的方式，说白了这就是我们如何被抚养长大以及灌输给我们的价值观和人格的华丽辞藻。女性通常被视为比男性更脆弱、更有同情心、更懂得付出和滋养，这是传统的共识，而男性则被视为更具冒险精神、更坚强、情绪较少。这就决定了他们如何与同性别的人建立联系和互动。那么让我先稍微解释一下这个。2016年，杜克大学曾做过一项非常酷的研究，旨在探究女性与女性友谊以及男性与男性友谊内部的区别。研究发现，女性在闲逛时往往更倾向于自我袒露。
So when we, you know, catch up with our friends, we're more likely to tell them about things that have happened in our life that have hurt us or excited us or that have caused us to be angry or sad, whatever it is, we're more likely to be vulnerable. Whilst men, when they get together, they often do a shared activity, or they're helping each other with a project or a task. I have seen this with my own boyfriend, where he prefers to play three hours of video games with his friends, whereas me and my girlfriends will go out for like a three-hour dinner and a three-hour chat.
所以当我们（你知道的）和朋友叙旧时，我们更有可能向她们倾诉生活中那些让我们受伤、让我们兴奋、或是让我们愤怒或悲伤的事情，无论是什么，我们更有可能展现脆弱。而男性聚在一起时，他们通常会进行一项共同的活动，或者他们是在互相帮忙完成一个项目或任务。我在我男朋友身上就看到过这一点，他更愿意和朋友玩三个小时的视频游戏，而我和我的闺蜜们则会出去吃三个小时的晚餐，聊三个小时。
And after he has seen his friends, it's like very typical. He's going out for a beer, they've gone to the beach. I'll be like, oh yeah, so like how is so-and-so's girlfriend like what's happening there like are they still together she's so nice i really like her like what's happening and he'll be like i don't know we didn't talk about it or i'll be like oh you know your friend how is his terrible job going like has he been able to find a new job i don't know again we didn't talk about it and it leaves me so confused because i'm like what else are you meant to talk about other than each other's lives like that's what a friend is for but obviously that's not
在他见过朋友之后，这非常典型。他会出去喝杯啤酒，他们去过海滩。我会说，“哦，对了，某某的女朋友怎么样了，那边有什么动静，他们还在一起吗？她太好了，我很喜欢她，到底怎么回事”，而他会说，“我不知道，我们没聊这个”；或者我会说，“哦，对了，你朋友那份糟糕的工作怎么样了，他找到新工作了吗？”，我又会得到回答，“我不知道，我们还是没聊这个”。这让我感到非常困惑，因为我想，除了彼此的生活，你们还能聊什么呢？朋友不就是为了这个吗？但很显然事实并非如此
really the case for him and like he has a preference or maybe a conditioned preference towards more of a hangout than a catch-up. So there was another 2017 study done on this from none other than Robin Dunbar. You may know him from Dunbar's number, which basically tells us how many friends we should or could have at a particular time. But he does a lot of research on like, he's a social psychologist. So a lot of his research is on how we interact, how we learn each other's behaviors, how we hang out, how we talk, how we gossip, all those things, how relationships are formed. And his research from 2017 found that women also tend to prefer to socialize one-on-one whilst men prefer to socialize in groups. Again, I see that
对他而言确实如此，他可能更倾向于（或者说经过条件反射更倾向于）闲逛而不是叙旧。因此，罗宾·邓巴（Robin Dunbar）在2017年又做了一项关于此的研究。你可能从“邓巴数”认识他，该数字基本上告诉了我们，在特定时间我们应该或能够拥有多少朋友。但他做了大量研究，比如，他是一名社会心理学家。因此他的很多研究都关于我们如何互动、我们如何学习彼此的行为、我们如何闲逛、我们如何交谈、我们如何八卦，所有这些事情，以及关系是如何形成的。他2017年的研究发现，女性也倾向于一对一地进行社交，而男性则更倾向于成群结队地社交。同样，我在自己的经历中也看到了这一点。
reflected in my own experiences. What's also different between women, women friendships and male-male friendships is that women tend to have higher expectations of their friends and they express greater disappointment upset at last minute cancellations of plans not seeing their friends for a while that sort of thing whereas men are kind of okay with their friends having agency even if it doesn't match what they want from them one final big thing that i found really really interesting and then i promise i'll i'll stop but women are more likely to have a best friend compared to men which again, checks out. So for a long time, friendships exhibited something we call gender homophily. Women were only friends with women, men are only friends with men. That has changed a lot recently.
女性友谊和男男友谊之间的另一个不同之处在于，女性往往对朋友抱有更高的期望，当最后一分钟取消计划或是一段时间没见朋友等情况发生时，她们会表现出更大的失望和沮丧，而男性则在某种程度上更能接受朋友有自主权，即使这不符合他们对朋友的期望。我发现的最后一个超级有趣的大重点，我向你们保证说完这个我就停下来：与男性相比，女性更有可能拥有一个最好的朋友，这一点再次得到了印证。因此，长期以来，友谊表现出一种我们称之为“性别同质性”的现象。女性只与女性交朋友，男性只与男性交朋友。这一点最近发生了很大的变化。
I want to explore how that shift took place. So the big factors trace back to society just becoming gradually more liberal, women entering the workforce more after World War I and World War II, the rise in co-ed schools and just more rights for women in general to exist in the in the public sphere rather than just at home so there was just more opportunities for exposure and for meeting and for friendship making but this really you know takes us back to this big million dollar question for all this progress for all the male-female friendships that we do see can men and women ever actually be friends without romantic attraction getting in the way, despite all of the progress,
我想探讨这种转变是如何发生的。主要的因素要追溯到社会逐渐变得更加包容、第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战后女性更多地进入职场、男女同校学校的兴起以及女性在公共领域而非仅仅局限于家庭中生存的整体权利的增加。因此，接触、见面和结交朋友的机会变得更多了。但这确实把我们带回了那个价值百万美元的宏大问题：对于所有的进步，对于我们所看到的所有的男女友谊，男女之间真的能毫无浪漫吸引力的干扰而成为真正的朋友吗？尽管取得了所有这些进步，
does romance still always find a way in? So I wanted to hear from you all, the listeners, before I reveal what the psychology says so far, and I asked you all over on Instagram, give me your perspective, what do you think, what have you seen happen in your own life? And the answers, your responses, they were split perfectly 50-50,
浪漫之情是否总是能找到介入的途径呢？因此，在我揭晓目前的心理学研究结果之前，我想听听你们这些听众的想法。我在Instagram上问了大家：请给我你们的看法，你们怎么看，你们在自己的生活中看到了什么？而大家的答案，你们的反应，竟然完全是50对50的分成两半，
right down the line, right down the middle, And also, no one who DM'd me had a neutral opinion. What I mean to say by that is that no one was messaging me saying, oh yeah, sometimes, yeah, sometimes no. It was either some of my best friends are men or women or the opposite gender, and I trust them and I love them more than anyone else, or this always ends in disaster. Stay away.
不偏不倚，恰好在中间。而且，发私信给我的所有人都没有持中立态度。我这么说是因为没有人发私信对我说，“哦，是的，有时候会，有时候不会。”要么就是“我最好的朋友中有一些是男性或女性，也就是异性，我信任他们，我爱他们胜过任何人”，要么就是“这总是以灾难告终。离远点吧”。
For example, I heard from one woman who said, her closest friends are all men, she has deep trust for them, they've known each other for almost a decade. And she was also in their wedding parties. I got a similar message from a guy who said he had recently emceived one of his female best friends weddings, how he will eventually include his female friends as part of his groomsmen. How he, and this was actually a really refreshing message.
例如，我听到一位女性说，她最要好的朋友全都是男性，她对他们有着深深的信任，他们认识快十年了。而且她还担任他们婚礼上的伴娘。我收到了一个男生发来的相似信息，他说他最近担任了一位女性挚友婚礼的司仪，他还打算最终让自己的女性朋友作为伴郎团的一部分。他说，而且这其实是一条非常令人耳目一新的信息。
He was like, my female friends have changed my worldview compared to some of my other mates. You know, like I see the world and I see life differently, which I was like, can't. This is actually quite beautiful. And that was reflected in another message from someone who was like my male friends have taught me what it means to be considerate and caring for someone in an unconditional way, which how beautiful is that? I also did get a few messages of like, men are just easier to deal with compared to women, which yeah, I'm sure that's the case for some people. I don't find that to be the case. Like, I think it's just different, but that was a common message. I also got. And then the other side of the coin, the DMs about male-female friendships that were
他说：我的女性朋友改变了我的世界观，这与我的一些其他哥们儿不同。你知道的，我以不同的方式看待世界和生活，当时我就觉得，这简直太棒了。这其实相当美丽。另一条来自某人的信息也反映了这一点，那人说：我的男性朋友教会了我，无条件地体贴和关怀一个人意味着什么。这简直太美妙了！我还收到了一些私信，大意是说：和女性相比，男性更好对付，对此，是的，我确信这对某些人来说确实如此。我并不觉得是这样。我觉得这只是有所不同，但这确实是一个常见的私信内容。我还收到了。然后硬币的另一面，关于男女友谊的私信是：
destroyed by someone catching feelings by deep betrayal in some cases trauma and hurt, jealousy and unrequited love, all very common. A surprising insight was that a lot of the DMs from women who had male friends actually said most of their male friends were gay or queer, which kind of supports the common argument, the male-female heterosexual friendships. They don't work because of sexual attraction, but when you take out that element, it can flourish. All of that aside, we are going to take a quick break and when we return, I want to talk about what makes male-female friendships so hard, why they fail, but also how to set boundaries, how to approach the friend zone and perhaps keep the friendship and so much more, so stay with us.
由于某人动了真情、在某些情况下遭受了深深的背叛、创伤和伤害、嫉妒以及单恋而遭到毁坏，这些都非常普遍。一个令人惊讶的见解是，许多拥有男性朋友的女性发来的私信实际上说，她们的大多数男性朋友都是同性恋或酷儿，这在某种程度上支持了一个常见的论点：男女异性恋友谊之所以行不通是因为性吸引力，但当你去除了这个因素，友谊就能蓬勃发展。抛开所有这些不谈，我们要稍事休息，等我们回来时，我想聊聊是什么让男女友谊如此艰难、为什么它们会失败，以及如何设定边界、如何处理“好友区”并或许保住友谊等等，所以请继续收听。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真诚地认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即I-HART-Radio应用、Apple-Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得黛安·罗斯在VMA上拍了小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look-Back-at-It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会在这里剖析发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何在其中幸存下来的。包括最近一集有马马克·拉蒙特·希尔参加的节目，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的霹雳可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为犯罪。可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看到其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在IHeart-Radio应用、Apple-Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look-Back-at-it。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
那是两个不同信任级别。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的I-Heart-Radio应用。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉尔西皮和迈克尔·马朗蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we're going to talk about the romance, the lust, the feelings, the Harry Met Sally situation, which is a great movie. I actually showed my boyfriend that movie the other day, and that's really, like, as
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被大陪审团以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。在Iheart-Radio应用、Apple-Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love-Trapped》播客。所以我们要谈论浪漫、欲望、感觉、哈利遇上莎莉的情况，这是一部很棒的电影。我前几天实际上向我的男朋友展示了那部电影，这真的就像
research, and we had a really interesting discussion about it. But firstly, I want to touch on some of the other reasons, less known, less thought of reasons, why male-female friendships may be a bit harder. The big first one is gender differences in emotional expression and communication styles. Try as we might. Men and women do emote differently and they have been socialized to show vulnerability, compassion, empathy in different ways. For men, empathy is often seen as a sign of weakness.
研究，我们对此进行了非常有趣的讨论。但首先，我想谈谈男女友谊可能更难维持的其他一些原因，这些原因不太为人所知，也不太常被思考。第一个大原因是情感表达和沟通风格上的性别差异。无论我们如何努力。男女确实以不同的方式表达情感，并且他们被社会化，以不同的方式表现脆弱、同情和共情。对男性来说，同情通常被视为软弱的标志。
For women, it's a sign of kindness, a good soul. It's a strength. So when you combine these reactions when you put them together, sometimes there can be this divide between what either party wants and what the other party gives. So I will say one of my closest friends, Jack, he's a guy and I've never experienced this with him. In fact, I think sometimes he's more sympathetic than some of my female friends. But I have seen this in other instances where a male friend is like, you know, they're there, like don't cry. child, and I can see that he's really struggling because he's never had to practice this skill. And so that does make it difficult if time and time again you realize that going to this person
对女性来说，这是善良、好心灵的标志。这是一种力量。因此，当你把这些反应结合起来，把它们放在一起时，有时在任何一方想要的和另一方给予的之间就会产生这种鸿沟。所以我得说我最亲密的朋友之一，杰克，他是个男生，我从未与他经历过这种情况。事实上，我觉得有时他比我的一些女性朋友更有同情心。但我确实在其他情况下看到过这种情况，比如一个男性朋友会说，你知道的，他们在那里，就像别哭一样。孩子，我能看出他真的很挣扎，因为他从未需要练习这项技能。因此，如果一次又一次地你意识到去找这个人
for emotional comfort isn't necessarily going to give you what you want. There was a DM I received from one person that matches this assumption. She said, I don't feel as comfortable around men. They don't show empathy. They have no idea what struggles. Women often have to face. I don't relate to them and I don't feel validated, which might be what some people feel
寻求情感慰藉不一定能给你想要的东西，这确实使事情变得困难。我收到过一个人发来的一条私信，符合这种假设。她说，我在男人身边感觉不够自在。他们不表现出同情。他们完全不知道女性经常要面对的挣扎。我无法与他们产生共鸣，也感觉不到自己的价值得到认可，这可能是有些人感受到的
and they just tend to find more support in people who get their lived experiences. And gender does influence how we experience the world. The second difficulty comes down to jealousy and insecurity from partners. And I think this is the problem with assuming all male-female friendships automatically have an underlying level of sexual attraction, it can ruin the friendship in other ways.
他们往往会在那些理解他们生活经历的人身上找到更多支持。性别确实会影响我们体验世界的方式。第二个困难归结为来自伴侣的嫉妒和不安全感。我认为这就是假设所有男女友谊自动具有潜在性吸引力水平的问题所在，它会在其他方面毁掉这段友谊。
It's the assumption that they do that ruins them, i.e., you know, when the boyfriend or the girlfriend or the partner of your friend feels insecure or jealous of your platonic bond, or they have a low, you know, residing level of competition. It's like a form of platonic retroactive jealousy almost and doubt. Even if there isn't no, there is no sexual attraction there. Some people do worry about emotional cheating. And they do see platonic friends of the opposite gender as a threat in that way. Like, why do you need to have female friends now that you have me?
正是这种它们确实如此的假设毁了它们，也就是，你知道的，当你的朋友的男友、女朋友或伴侣对你们的柏拉图式羁绊感到不安或嫉妒时，或者他们有一种较低的、你知道的，内在的竞争水平。这几乎是一种柏拉图式的回溯性嫉妒和怀疑的形式。即使根本没有，那里也没有性吸引力。有些人确实担心情感出轨。他们确实认为异性的柏拉图式朋友是那种方式的威胁。就像，既然你有了我，为什么你还需要有女性朋友？
Why do you need male friends when you have me as if, you know, gender is the only thing that defines the bond? I received a message from someone who said that she had been friends with her guy friends for over a decade. However, when they started getting into relationships, they stopped talking to her. her and now they have no relationship at all and I think the assumption there is that their girlfriends probably maybe weren't comfortable with them having such a close female friend. One woman said, and this actually shocked me when I got this, she said, my male best friend's ex used to accuse me of hit and running her car so that I would get in trouble with him. Like when I read that message, I was like, oh my God, like the image of that, like this woman showing up and like somehow
既然有了我，你为什么还需要男性朋友，好像，你知道的，性别是定义这种羁绊的唯一东西。我收到一个人的信息，她说她和她的男性朋友做了十多年的朋友。然而，当他们开始谈恋爱时，他们就不再和她说话了。他们现在根本没有联系，我认为那里的假设是他们的女朋友可能不太习惯他们有这样一个亲密的女性朋友。一个女人说，当我得到这个消息时，这实际上震惊了我，她说，我最好的男性朋友的前女友曾经指控我撞了她的车，这样我就会惹上麻烦。就像当我读到那条信息时，我是天哪，像那种形象，就像这个女人出现并且不知何故
finding a way to dent her car to blame this friend of her of her partner is just ridiculous and I honestly think that does indicate already a general insecurity or lack of trust that is goes far beyond a male female friendship but for some people they just can't understand again why you need friends of the opposite gender when you have a partner I'm going to say this and I don't like to make hot takes like this, but I don't think that's particularly socially intelligent to have that assumption. But I also respect that if you've been burned by past experiences, maybe this does feel like a natural protective reaction. Like I don't want to be hurt again. This is a past, you know, a past situation that has hurt me. So I'm going to have boundaries and rules for myself,
找到一种方法去凹陷她的车来指责她伴侣的这个朋友，这太荒谬了，我老实说这确实已经表明了一种普遍的不安全感或缺乏信任，这远远超出了男女友谊的范畴，但对某些人来说，他们就是无法理解，当你有了一个伴侣时，你为什么还需要异性的朋友。我要这么说，我不喜欢发表这种激进的观点，但我不认为持有这种假设在社会上是特别聪明的。但我也尊重，如果你曾被过去的经历灼伤，也许这确实感觉像是一种自然的保护性反应。就像我不想再次受到伤害。这是一个过去的，你知道的，伤害过我的过去情况。所以我要为自己设定界限和规则，
which if it works for you, it works for you. I do just think that it's nuanced and it's case by case. it is something I used to be very aware of in my male friendships because, you know, I didn't want to come off as threatening. I didn't want to come off as like someone anyone had to be worried about. But as I've gotten older, you know, I've expected more maturity from people. Like, I've known this person for eight years. Of course, if either of us had any kind of feeling, we would have figured it out by now. Like, you're okay. Like, I do really think that as you get older, it gets easier as well because you're like, yeah, again, if it was going to happen, it would have happened.
如果它对你管用，那就管用。我只是认为这是微妙的，具体情况具体分析。这曾经是我在男性友谊中非常注意的一点，因为，你知道的，我不想显得具有威胁性。我不想显得像一个任何人需要担心的人。但随着我年龄的增长，你知道的，我对人们有了更多的成熟度期望。就像，我认识这个人八年了。当然，如果我们俩有任何感觉，我们早就弄清楚了。就像，你没事。就像，我真的认为随着你年龄增长，这也变得更容易了，因为你会觉得，是的，再说一次，如果它要发生，它早就发生了。
so we're in the clear. But if you do believe male-female friendships always end with someone getting feelings, it is a hard intuition to move past. So let's talk about it now. Let's finally get to this point. I want to talk about one study in particular from 2012 published in Scientific America. So for this study, they wanted to see male-female friendships, possible, not possible. What is the threat of sexual attraction?
所以我们安全了。但如果你真的相信男女友谊总是以某人产生好感告终，那是一种很难放下的直觉。所以我们现在来谈谈。让我们终于谈到这一点。我想特别谈谈2012年发表在《科学美国人》上的一项研究。所以对于这项研究，他们想看看男女友谊，可能，不可能。性吸引力的威胁是什么？
So they brought in 88 pairs of undergraduate opposite sex friends into a science lab, and they separated them. But before they did, they made both friends promise verbally in front of each other that they weren't going to talk about the study with each other afterwards. Anything said in the separate rooms would be private. Have a guess what they asked them. Well, they took them into separate rooms and they said, all right, this friend that you brought today,
因此，他们把88对本科生异性朋友带到一个科学实验室，并将他们分开。但在他们这样做之前，他们让两个朋友在彼此面前口头承诺，事后绝不互相谈论这项研究。在分开的房间里说的任何话都是保密的。猜猜他们问了他们什么。好吧，他们把他们带到不同的房间，然后说，好吧，你今天带来的这个朋友，
would you ever consider dating this person? Have you ever felt attracted to this person? Would you like your future partner to have qualities like your friend? Do you want to ask them out? Do you think they feel the same way about you? That your feelings are reciprocated? Here is what the results said. Men were much more attracted to their female friends than vice versa.
你是否曾考虑过和这个人约会？你曾对这个人产生过好感吗？你希望你未来的伴侣具备像你朋友这样的品质吗？你想约他们出去吗？你认为他们对你也有同感吗？你的感觉是相互回应的吗？结果如下。男性对女性朋友的吸引力远大于女性对男性朋友的吸引力。
So they were more likely to say, yeah, I think she's really hot. I would date her. they were also more likely than the women to think that their opposite sex friend was attracted to them, even when it wasn't the case. So a lot of the men were saying, I have feelings for her, I think she's attractive, and I think she feels the same about me. And really that had virtually nothing to do with how these women actually felt. Most of the men would just say it in general.
所以他们更有可能说，是的，我觉得她真的很火。我会和她约会。他们也比女性更有可能认为他们的异性朋友被他们吸引，即使实际情况并非如此。所以很多男性都在说，我对她有好感，我觉得她很有吸引力，而且我认为她对我也一样。而这实际上与这些女性的真实感受几乎没有什么关系。大多数男性只是泛泛而谈。
There was no pattern. Like it wasn't like they were picking up on cues. They just assumed romantic attraction, and they assumed that it was mutual. Women, though, they were also a little bit blind, and they were blind to the mindset of their opposite sex friend. So some of them were attracted to their male friends. Most of them, though, weren't. And when they were, they didn't assume that their attraction was mutual.
没有什么规律。就像他们不是在捕捉线索。他们只是假设浪漫吸引力，并且他们假设这是相互的。然而，女性也有点盲目，她们对异性朋友的心态视而不见。所以她们中的一些人确实被她们的男性朋友吸引了。不过，大多数人没有。当她们被吸引时，她们并不认为这种吸引力是相互的。
So they weren't being like, oh yeah, he would totally. date me. They were a bit more cautious. They were also more sensitive to their male friend's relationship status. They were more likely to say that they were uninterested in pursuing their friend because they were already involved with someone else. Men just didn't really seem to care. Basically, the age-old wisdom may be true, but it's not women who struggle with being just friends. it's the men, which is perhaps why the friend zone often is filled with a lot of guys and not so many women. Now, before we jump to conclusions, I really want to say a lot of people do and will look at this study and be like, well, there you go. That's it.
所以她们不会像，哦，是的，他绝对会。和我约会。她们要谨慎得多。她们也对男性朋友的恋爱状态更加敏感。她们更有可能表示自己对追求朋友不感兴趣，因为对方已经和别人在一起了。男性似乎并不太在意。基本上，老生常谈可能是真的，但并不是女性在仅仅作为朋友这件事上苦苦挣扎。是男性，这也许就是为什么“好人区”常常充斥着很多男人而不是那么多女性的原因。现在，在我们下结论之前，我真的想说，很多人确实会、也将来看待这项研究并觉得，好吧，就是这样。
It proves it. It's impossible. Men and women can't be friends. It's in the science. That's simply not true. Not every person or every man or every woman in this study. answered the exact same way. There were male participants
它证明了这一点。这是不可能的。男女不能做朋友。科学证明了这一点。这根本不是真的。在这项研究中，并不是每个人或每个男性或每个女性。都以完全相同的方式回答。有男性参与者
who did see their friends completely platonically and as did their female friend. So one thing we need to understand about any kind of psychological research, no one study is going to prove something. And it's definitely not going to give you a result with 100% significance. And the same is to be said about this study.
他们确实完全以柏拉图式的方式看待他们的朋友，女性朋友也是如此。因此，关于任何类型的心理学研究，我们需要理解的一点是，没有哪一项研究能证明某件事。它绝对不会给你一个具有100%显著性的结果。关于这项研究也是如此。
We cannot take those findings and apply them to everyone, also because there were only 88 people involved. So only 44 groups of friends. I also think that if attraction was the only issue, lesbians wouldn't be able to be friends with straight women, yet they are. Gay men wouldn't be able to be friends with straight men. Bisexual individuals wouldn't be able to be friends with anyone. And that's obviously not true. Just because you may think someone is attractive, it doesn't mean that you'll necessarily act on it. We do have self-control, so we want to take a
我们不能把这些发现应用到每个人身上，同样是因为只有88人参与。所以只有44组朋友。我还认为，如果吸引力是唯一的问题，女同性恋将无法与直女做朋友，然而她们可以。男同性恋将无法与直男做朋友。双性恋个人将无法与任何人做朋友。这显然是不对的。仅仅因为你可能认为某人有吸引力，并不意味着你一定会采取行动。我们确实有自控力，所以我们想采取一个
nuanced approach to these findings. But it does really lead me to my next point. What does it take for men and women to be friends? Is there a bit of a checklist or common factors that unite successful platonic male-female friendships in some way? Well, I want to find out and report back my findings. And this was the kind of checklist that I came up with. The checklist for a successful male, female friendship. Number one, I think neither party can be secretly attracted to the other because this creates a pining, unrequited love situation where someone is bound to be hurt whilst, you know, either they're waiting for the other person's feelings to change or they're also waiting for the feeling to go away. Like when you're in that situation, in that emotional limbo, you are just going to be
对这些发现采取微妙的态度。但这确实引导我谈到下一个观点。男人和女人要成为朋友需要什么？成功的柏拉图式男女友谊之间是否存在某种核对清单或共同因素？好吧，我想找出答案并汇报我的发现。这就是我列出的核对清单。成功建立男女友谊的清单。第一，我认为双方都不能对彼此怀有暗恋，因为这会造成一种单相思、一厢情愿的局面，势必会有人受伤，而与此同时，你知道，要么他们在等待对方的心意改变，要么他们在等待这种感觉消失。就像当你处于那种情况、那种情感的悬而未决状态时，你只会
repeatedly hurt, I think. And you're going to have expectations for the relationship that aren't the expectations that you would have for a purely platonic friend. The other thing about unrequited love is that it makes it really hard to walk away, even when you know you should because the possibility of the what if or your hypothetical feeling about the situation feels so real. Like you are waiting for things to change when it might not and it probably won't. If you cross that line as well, if you do have sex or if you do say, I really feel for you, I want to date you. It can be hard to come back from.
不断受到伤害，我认为。而且你对这段关系会抱有期望，而这些期望并不是你对一个纯粹的柏拉图式朋友所抱有的期望。关于单相思的另一件事是，它让人很难放手，即使你知道自己应该放手，因为“如果……会怎样”的可能性或者你对这种情况的假设感觉太真实了。就像你在等待事情改变，而它可能不会改变，而且很可能不会改变。如果你也跨过了那条线，如果你确实发生了性行为，或者如果你确实说，我真的很喜欢你，我想和你约会。这很难回头。
It is very difficult, and I want everyone to hear this, it is very difficult to come back from being friends with benefits to just friends unless it is purely transactional. but of course it never is because you're friends you know you already had a prior emotional bond so you obviously at least in a slim sense like them you've kept up a friendship with them so you can't kid yourself and say it's just sex it's just physical because you know the feeling most likely originated from a more mental place one of kinship friendship mutual respect liking like you were friends for a reason and that blossomed into it. sexual attraction. Now it's more than just that. You know, it's two things combined. Think about all the
这非常困难，我希望每个人都听到这句话，从炮友关系退回普通朋友非常困难，除非这种关系纯粹是交易性的。但当然，它绝不可能是纯粹的交易，因为你们是朋友，你知道你们之前已经有了情感纽带，所以你显然至少在微小的意义上喜欢他们，你一直和他们保持着友谊，所以你不能自欺欺人地说这只是性，这只是身体上的，因为你知道这种感觉很可能是源于更精神的层面，一种亲属关系、友谊、相互尊重、喜欢，就像你们成为朋友是有原因的，而这演变成了性吸引力。现在，它不仅仅是那样了。你知道，这是两件事的结合。想想所有
movies that have been made about this, all the storylines in television shows like friends, like the office, like parks and recreation. I could literally name dozens. They all have a predictable ending. Either they end up together, which is the best case scenario or the friendship disintegrates because it can't remain in that ambiguous whatever we are zone forever. And when you have to be, to either move on or commit. What if both people aren't on the same page? One of you wants to move on. One of you wants to commit. The friendship's done. So yes, no attraction, definitely no sex. Second, a successful male-female friendship or any friendship for that matter needs to be respectful, gender aside. And honestly, that's what I really heard from a lot of women who damned me.
以此为题材拍摄的电影，电视剧中的所有剧情，比如《老友记》、《办公室》、《公园与游憩》。我简直能说出几十部。它们都有一个可预测的结局。要么他们最终走到一起，这是最好的情况，要么友谊破裂，因为它无法永远停留在那种含糊不清的“无论我们是什么关系”的地带。当你们不得不做出抉择时，要么继续前进，要么做出承诺。如果两人的意见不一致呢？你们中有一个人想继续前进。你们中有一个人想做出承诺。这段友谊就结束了。所以，是的，没有吸引力，绝对没有性。第二，成功的男女友谊或任何友谊都需要互相尊重，抛开性别不谈。老实说，这就是我从许多发私信给我的女性那里听到的。
it was that their male friendships ended because of a lack of respect and a failure to learn or understand their perspective. So there has to be respect for each other's opinions, perspectives and individuality. And I'm going to say it again, like any friendship can end from a lack of respect. But since men and women have been socialized to show respect differently, I think it can be a learning process for some people.
她们的男性朋友关系之所以破裂，是因为缺乏尊重，以及未能了解或理解她们的视角。因此，必须尊重彼此的意见、观点和个性。我要再说一遍，任何友谊都可能因为缺乏尊重而终结。但由于男女被社会化以不同的方式表现尊重，我认为对某些人来说，这可能是一个学习的过程。
And so, yeah, again, gender aside, you need this. And kind of links to the next thing, which is emotional safety. You have to feel emotionally supported and safe in confiding in them. And if you're perhaps a woman who has previously had bad experiences with male behavior, that emotional safety can be hard and that can make male friendships difficult following a betrayal. With that, we also need mutual trust as well and equality in the friendship. So both parties are putting in effort, both are putting in attention, time, that can be difficult because as we discussed before,
所以，是的，再次抛开性别不谈，你需要这个。这与下一件事有点联系，那就是情感安全。你必须在向他们倾诉时感到情感上的支持和安全。如果你可能是一个以前有过对男性行为不良经历的女性，那么这种情感安全可能会很难建立，在经历背叛之后，这可能会让男女友谊变得困难。除此之外，我们还需要相互信任以及友谊中的平等。因此，双方都在付诸努力，都在付出关注和时间，这可能很困难，因为正如我们之前所讨论的，
differing expectations between men and women when it comes to friendship can cause this to become a source of friction. And finally, I think for male-female friendships to be successful, there has to be an absence of jealousy, particularly around others' romantic relationships. So partners of these people cannot be jealous, people within the friendship cannot be jealous of the partners. And I think that jealousy in this case, like when a guy gets a girlfriend and suddenly, you know, his female friend gets quite upset and distressed, that reaction is really just a proxy, again, for romantic interest.
男女在友谊方面的期望不同，这可能会导致其成为摩擦的根源。最后，我认为男女友谊要获得成功，必须没有嫉妒，特别是围绕其他人浪漫关系的嫉妒。因此，这些人的伴侣不能嫉妒，友谊中的人也不能嫉妒伴侣。我认为在这种情况下，嫉妒——比如当一个男生交了女朋友，突然间，你知道，他的女性朋友变得非常沮丧和心烦意乱——这种反应其实只是浪漫兴趣的一种替代表现。
So it links back to that big umbrella point. You can't be attracted to each other. Basically, I think a lot of these points go beyond gender. If they're a good person, they'll be a good friend. And I don't think, at least I hope those aren't hard criteria to meet. and in all honesty I think it's really worth finding friends of the opposite gender that you can trust and care about and vice versa. Obviously it's not a necessity for some of us, but if you can get it right, it is really rewarding because you do see a whole new perspective.
所以这又回到了那个大伞形观点。你们不能互相吸引。基本上，我认为很多这些观点都超越了性别。如果他们是个好人，他们就会是个好朋友。而且我不认为，至少我希望这些不是难以满足的标准。老实说，我认为非常值得去寻找你可以信任和关心的异性朋友，反之亦然。显然，对我们有些人来说这不是必需的，但如果你能处理好，它确实非常有回报，因为你会看到一个全新的视角。
You may even see the world differently. I also had one message from someone who was a woman and she has autism and she says, you know, being around men allowed me to finally learn how. how people interact because they're so much more straightforward. So I learned a lot of social skills from them. Men may also experience less judgment and more validation and emotional safety with their female friends. So we are getting things from the other person's perspective.
你甚至可能会以不同的方式看待世界。我还收到过一条消息，发信人是一位女性，她患有自闭症，她说，你知道，和男性在一起让我最终学会了人们是如何互动的，因为他们直率得多。所以我从他们那里学到了很多社交技巧。男性也可能在女性朋友那里体验到更少的评判，以及更多的认可和情感安全。所以我们正在从对方的角度获取东西。
Even if it does look different to how you would hang out with friends of the same gender, i.e. it's more activity based or it's coffee and a chat rather than playing soccer or whatever. I think everyone does bring something new based on themselves as individuals and gender is a facet of who we are. So bringing a different perspective, whether you are male, female, non-binary, like that is important and allows people to see things differently. I will admit, for many, a lot of the comments I received said it is becoming harder because of how gender has been weaponised in politics and in our circumstances. society recently. It does feel like there is a bigger social and psychological divide between men and women. So this amazing article from Vox actually interviewed people about this after the US election and found that there is a lot of social momentum pushing men and women apart, you know, from
即使这看起来与你和同性朋友聚会的方式不同，即更多地基于活动，或者是喝咖啡聊天，而不是踢足球之类的事情。我认为每个人都会根据他们作为个体的自身带来新的东西，而性别是我们身份的一个方面。因此，带来不同的视角，无论你是男性、女性、非二元性别，这都是重要的，并且能让人以不同的方式看待事物。我必须承认，对许多人来说，我收到的许多评论都说，由于近年来性别在政治和我们的社会中被武器化，这种关系变得越来越困难。感觉男女之间存在着更大的社会和心理鸿沟。因此，《Vox》上这篇精彩的文章实际上在美大选后就此采访了人们，并发现有许多社会动能正在把男人和女人推开，你知道，从
reproductive rights to which parties young men versus young women choose to vote for, how social media has become more intense and pushed men into these weird corners of the internet that nobody, quite frankly, needs to be in. Like, it has made it harder to see eye to eye. And I get it. If you're in the US and you're a woman whose basic reproductive rights have been squashed and you have a male friend who just doesn't really seem to get it or doesn't really seem to care how serious this is, it can take a toll. You don't feel seen. And that's not good for any friendship but furthermore the difference has become more apparent because of you know how society is currently being i don't know how it's being manipulated and how it's different from how it was before
生殖权利到年轻男性与年轻女性选择投票给哪个政党，再到社交媒体变得更加极端，将男性推向互联网上那些坦白说谁都不需要的奇异角落。这一切使得彼此达成共识变得更加困难。我懂。如果你在美国，你是一个女性，你的基本生殖权利被剥夺了，而你有一个男性朋友，他似乎并不真正理解或并不真正在乎这件事有多严重，这可能会付出代价。你觉得没有被看见。这对任何友谊都不好，而且此外，这种差异变得更加明显，因为你知道社会目前是如何被——我不知道它是如何被操纵的，以及它与以前有何不同
it's harder to overlook and i think a lot of resentment can also arise but i also don't want to see us go back to pre-1950s or 1960s when male-female friendship was even more rare and strange and I think that will occur if we continue to believe that men and women can't be friends, if we continue to suggest that there is always romantic sexual attraction. And I think that just stretches the divide further and it means that we are less able to learn from each other. But I'd also love to hear your opinions as well because I do believe men and women can be friends if there is no sexual attraction. And I do think that there are a lot of situations where that isn't the case.
这更难忽视，我认为也会产生很多怨恨。但我也同样不希望我们回到20世纪50年代或60年代之前，那时男女友谊甚至更为罕见和怪异。如果我们继续认为男人和女人不能成为朋友，如果我们继续暗示总是存在浪漫的性吸引力，我认为这种情况就会发生。我认为这只会进一步扩大鸿沟，这意味着我们更无法互相学习。不过我也很想听听你们的意见，因为我坚信，如果没有性吸引力，男人和女人是可以成为朋友的。而且我认为在很多情况下并非如此。
And I also think that it's possible to have really respectful male-female friendships that are reciprocal, that are, you know, work for both people, where there is emotional validation and emotional safety and listening. All those things are possible. I do want to hear your opinions, though. I would also really love to see more research on non-binary, bisexual, transgender friendship preferences, because I think that could just give us such an amazing insight and more. more knowledge about why we do see a divide between genders when it comes to friendships. And I think it could also undo so many assumptions about, you know, attraction, friendship, preferences, lifestyle, like dating, jealousy, all those things. So if anyone needs a fun research project, you can have that one.
我也认为建立真正尊重、互惠的男女友谊是可能的，这种友谊对双方都管用，其中存在情感认可、情感安全和倾听。所有这些都是可能的。不过我确实想听听你们的意见。我也非常希望看到更多关于非二元性别、双性恋、跨性别友谊偏好的研究，因为我认为这可以为我们提供如此惊人的洞察力，以及更多关于为什么我们在友谊方面看到性别鸿沟的知识。我认为这也可以消除关于吸引力、友谊、偏好、生活方式、约会、嫉妒等方面的许多假设。所以如果有人需要一个有趣的研究项目，你可以选这个。
That one is for you. Please do it. Report back your findings. I would love to hear about it. But just to summarize, again, I think male, female friendships are possible, but they don't come without difficulty. Some of the difficulties are attraction. They are that men and women have been socialized differently. They are a difference in lived experiences that can create a divide. But if there is respect, if there is, you know,
那个项目是留给你的。请去做吧。汇报你的发现。我很想听听。但总而言之，我认为男女友谊是可能的，但并非没有困难。其中的一些困难在于吸引力。它们在于男女被社会化得不同。它们在于生活经历的差异，这会造成鸿沟。但如果有尊重，如果有，你知道的，
no interest in a romantic partnership, if there is emotional safety, mutual trust, an ability to listen to each other, I think it's beyond possible. And you can, learn so much. You can learn so much. It always reminds me of those like videos that I used to watch on YouTube back on the day of like questions women want to ask men or the biggest questions girls have for guys answered. And I think that like when you have friends of all genders, either gender of just a variety of people, your worldview is more expansive. So yeah, that's what I hope for at least. Thank you again for listening to this episode. If you have feedback, thoughts, questions, please drop a comment below. I would love to hear from you. If you have made it this far,
对浪漫伴侣没有兴趣，如果有情感安全、相互信任、倾听彼此的能力，我认为这完全超越了可能。而且你可以学到很多东西。你可以学到很多东西。它总是让我想起我过去在YouTube上看的那些老视频，比如女人想问男人的问题，或者女孩对男人的最大疑问得到了解答。我认为，当你拥有各种性别的朋，或者是各种各样的人的朋友时，你的世界观就会变得更加广阔。所以，是的，这是我至少所期望的。再次感谢收听本期节目。如果你有反馈、想法、问题，请在下方留言。我很想听到你们的声音。如果你能听到这里，
what's the emoji I'm going to choose today? I'm going to choose the little friend emoji, like the two people holding hands. So if you've made it this far, drop that below. So I can say hi and I can see who are the true listeners, who are the loyal listeners. If you want to suggest an episode, this episode was very hugely massively suggested and that's why I did it. So I do obviously cave into public pressure. You can DM me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. Just make sure that you're following along there as well to get episode summaries to see what's coming up next, to vote on future episodes and give stories like the ones that were provided
今天要选的表情符号是什么？我要选那个小小的朋友表情符号，就像两个人手拉手那样。所以如果你坚持听到了这里，请在下方留下它。这样我就可以打个招呼，看看谁是真正的听众，谁是忠实听众。如果你想建议一期节目，这期节目就是被大众非常强烈地建议的，这就是我为什么做它的原因。所以我显然向公众压力妥协了。你可以在Instagram上私信我，账号是that psychology podcast。只要确保你在那里保持关注，以获取节目总结，了解接下来会发生什么，为未来的节目投票，并提供像这里提供的那样的故事
here. Make sure you're following along. Give us a five-star review. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself above all else. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keir Games.
确保你一直在关注。给我们一个五星好评。直到下一次，保重，保持善良，最重要的是对自己温柔。我们很快就会谈到。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Keir Games）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去这么做，
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern.
我的大脑都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《被困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧度、健身以及在我们奇异现代生活中建立韧性的科学。
and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并担忧。让自己经历一些磨难，你会作为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的普通人从另一端走出来。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。